leute was soll das eigentlich sonne
scheint angenehmer wind
warum kommt jetzt warum kommt jetzt noch
in baden im video nach all den videos
sie schon auf youtube grad warm sein
matthew barney die u-bahn im schleim
baden chicken wings eigentlich muss
nicht sein oder
doch denn mit dem heutigen video machen
wir einen deckel drauf diese ganze
geschichte der wir machen heute das
ultimative baden im video bisher jeder
wie du bist in seiner badewanne den
dingen gebadet und das finde ich
ziemlich langweilig und habe mir gerade
wenn man jetzt sagen will ok genug von
dem scheiß trend es reicht mitteilung
dass da wenn ich eigentlich nicht
schlecht wenn man jetzt mal einen
draufsetzt wir sind hier an einer etwas
größeren badewannen titel gelesen haben
sich dachten 50.000 was wir jetzt sagen
dass sie gesagt ist der bodensee und der
bodensee enthält ungefähr 50 milliarden
kubikmeter wasser eine normale badewanne
passen ungefähr 150 liter die 150 litern
einer badewanne sind ungefährt ziemlich
genau 0 1 5 kubikmeter holz
ich schon echt schon oft ihr euch immer
gefragt
wie viele badewannen chicken wings auch
man eigentlich um den bodensee
wirklich gefunden
bis jetzt war jetzt gucken wir 50
milliarden kubikmeter sind das hier und
in der badewanne passen 0,15 kubikmeter
also teil der 50 milliarden durch 0,1
füllen sollte man braucht mehr oder
weniger 333 milliarden 333 millionen
daran dass 1333 3333 badewannen
anschicken rings um den bodensee zu
füllen aber wir müssen gar nicht füllen
weil da schon wasser drin ist man
deswegen dürfen wir heute eine sache
noch bevor wir loslegen
ich hab mir so ein zwei baden in videos
angeschaut ich habe ich den eindruck
dass 90 prozent aller youtuber die sowas
machen sich wie hyperaktive spaß dieses
verhalten in diesen videos da heißt es
zum beispiel nicht hey leute waren diese
menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend wie kann man sich sogar so
eine scheiße freund ich habe eigentlich
gefühl um heute auf youtube videos zu
machen muss man hyperaktiv sein aber ich
glaube ganz ehrlich da wir zuschauer
keinen bock drauf und hab ich hab keinen
bock drauf
deswegen verhalten wie ganz normale
menschen jetzt haben in diesem scheiss
junge dass es so kalt was ist los so
haben wir nicht gewettet was nicht
heissen so kalt also ich bin ja nicht
die profis spielen aber das wasser ist
aixtron hat dafür verdammt halten die
steine
das abbrechen
das ist die moralische unterstützung der
kameramann erwartet wenn man sagt so
etwas abläuft sind
wisst ihr warum der bodensee bodensee
heißt
schaut euch mal um ja man kann den boden
sehen ist okay aber jetzt kommt
die schleimigen schreiben also ein
raster wie sand aussieht dass irgendeine
höllen substanz man das hat mich gerade
eben so richtig runter gezogen wenn ich
jetzt sterben bei diesem körper kommt
die person die als erstes hashtag press
kay die kommentare statt main kanal
bönnigheim gehortet euro
das ist echt krank wird einmal leben
retten also ich will nicht leugnen aber
irgendwas hat mich am großen zeh am
linken fuss gerade gebissen oder
gestochen was für helen wesen lauern da
in diesen beiden welten ganz der medien
ich kann nicht mehr ich will nicht dass
ihr zeit macht aber macht es sauber ich
will dass ihr das sauber macht nun mit
dem linken bein
ok